we visited the LOS angeles-based band la
Santa Cecilia at their concert in New
York to talk about their single winning
which uses elements from bachata as
background for a poem about the evils of
social media
I wear rainbows as skirts to Cowboys
build a fire there's a guy eating a
flower describing winning musically huh
like a pop rock but chat the spoken word
punk rocky rocky Sun so what is bachata
bachata is a Latin American music genre
from the Dominican Republic that is
rising in popularity across the world
just look at bachata oh Romeo Santos the
face of bachata for many he has billions
of views on YouTube and he's performed a
sold-out show to 80,000 fans at New
Jersey's MetLife Stadium I have to admit
I have never heard of bachata before and
especially with the genre is blurring
it's kind of hard to tell what exactly
is bachata or not later on I'm going to
attempt to create my own bachata track
but first let's break down the musical
DNA of what makes bachata bachata
[Music]
we interviewed la Santa Cecilia about
how bachata has inspired them this is
what they had to say but to be one
chapter is like like a bolero and I grew
up singing boleros with Pepe that's I
mean that's what we played when we were
younger all these beautiful like
romantic ballads he plays a requinto and
but it's also very post a minister it's
traditional right - so definitely in
traditional I mean like a lot of it's
like a Caribbean kind of rhythm I mean
there's a lot of artists like a money's
Guerra
well who has been an influence for us
and this is just like a danceable kind
of rhythm that we you know that we're
we're used to it's music that's played
in in cantinas where people are drinking
and and and and and and feeling things
in a very like sensual sometimes
passionate very like you know meaningful
way so it's like music the men listen to
and cry and dance and you know it's kind
of one of those kind of like amia kind
of things you know that that inspires us
a lot in the band yeah cuz the main
feature on the verses is a spoken word
part and then and then if you're
listening carefully you'll notice that
there's a bachata rhythm underneath
[Music]
so where did bachata come from it was
born in a Dominican Republic and for
much of its history it wasn't held in
such high regard in those days bachata
songs used acoustic instruments like
this for 1930 until 1961 the Dominican
Republic was under the control of
dictator Rafael Trujillo during his
three decade role through he Oh censored
a lot of the creative arts and only
sanctioned music was recorded during
this time however a live music scene
flourished and this is where bachata was
born within six months of Trujillo's
assassination in 1961 the first bachata
track was recorded by Jose Manuel
Calderon these early bachata songs used
equipment recovered from government
radio stations listen to this early
track by Rafael and collosseum
[Music]
this song has a 1 6 2 5 1 chord
progression which is a common chord
progression found in bachata music at
the time though the music wasn't yet
known as bachata instead it was
considered to be a form of bolero which
is an older Latin style of music that
has similarities to a jazz ballad a
defining feature of this is the bass
line with this type of rhythm which
emphasizes B and 3 for these uniquely
Dominican bolero songs were given the
name bachata by the upper-class to
disparage to the music the word bachata
is Caribbean Spanish for an informal
party during this time bachata music was
often associated with poverty crime and
sensuality and found little airtime on
the radio or television another
ingredient in bachata is the rhythm
commonly known as le Marcio or the
hammer commonly played on the bongos it
has a lot in common with the Bongo
rhythm of bolero
unlike most rhythms it emphasizes the 4
instead of the 1
[Music]
when batata modernized its guitar solos
began to employ Mambo's or short
repeating rhythmic melodies you can also
call them grooves but Java is music
intended for dancing we're old-fashioned
bachata x' were danced more slowly the
introduction of these Mambo's made it
possible for dancers to enjoy boleros
sensual romanticism and Merengues upbeat
energy within the same song listen for
the Mambo is played by Anthony Santos a
defining figure in the evolution of
modern electric bachata another
important aspect of modern bachata is a
rhythmic pattern commonly played by the
lead guitar its arpeggiating triads and
it goes one two three one two three two
three one two three one two three two
three
it's unique because it's dividing the
group of four quarter note beats into
two groups of three eighth notes one two
three one two three plus a group of two
eighth notes two three one two three one
two three two three and as you can hear
it's naturally emphasizing the fourth
beat that appreciation has become a
signature element in bachata listen to
it in medicina de amor by Raul in
Rodrigues
in the 1990s but Tata went through
another big shift aventura a new york
band led by romeo santos fused bachata
with hip-hop R&B and rock and even
sprinkled english into the lyrics the
result was a new urban style of bachata
[Music]
with aventura success but shot that
became an overnight worldwide pop
sensation the urban style of bachata
centred around New York City has since
dominated over patatas expanding
worldwide audience many fans of bachata
outside of the Dominican Republic don't
even realize that other forms of it
exist so what's next for bachata it's
not going to stop evolving that's for
sure nowadays artists are recording
bachata is also in English and Italian
and many are reinterpreting pop songs
from various traditions with the
chocolate rhythms for example another
batch of pharoah from New York City
Prince Royce has a major hit of a
bachata version of stand by me by Benny
King
[Music]
some bunch of effusions are more
experimental let's go back to winning by
la Santa Cecilia upon first listen it
sounds nothing like the bachata as we've
listened to so far but it contains many
of the elements that we mentioned for
example it has the one two three one two
three two three arpeggiated pattern
plate by the guitars it also has the one
six two five one chord progression and
there's even a bongo playing a bachata
[Music]
in the spirit of fusion I'm going to
remix the song create create into a
chiptune track inspired by retro video
game music I think a lot of the patterns
and progressions use will fit really
nicely with this type of sound if you
liked this episode and want more don't
forget to subscribe and hit the
notification
[Music]